hi guys so there's five steps to the
creative process
that kind of spans all across the board
whether you're an architect or a writer
so let me just start off by saying that
there are no
new ideas the creative process is the
act of taking old ideas
and creating new connections between
them or seeing them in a new life you're
never starting from a blank slate
in fact that would be kind of terrifying
you're taking existing constraints
you're taking old ideas and you're just
combining them
in a way that's never been done before
so in his book
a technique for producing ideas james
webb young
describes the five processes and i've
just added a couple
of my own and so the first step is
gathering
you're gathering all the data all the
information there is to know about your
topic
about areas around your topic and also
learning about concepts from other areas
that might relate to your topic for
example when i was doing research for my
thesis
which was a library i was researching
about
the history of books you know the
cognitive psychology behind
reading monasteries the parisian arcades
and then collecting all the data around
libraries that exist now and that has
existed before
and doing a very thorough case study and
the second step
is processing that's when you look at
all the data you've gathered
and you try to see how you can fit them
into different
angles and combine them in ways that
hasn't been combined before
and the third step is you try to come up
with a solution
at a certain point you have to stop
researching
and you have to start designing try to
come up with solutions
come up with five solutions come up with
10 solutions
the more the better the more solutions
you try to come up with
you'll be able to see what works and
what doesn't work
you have to think by doing and number
four
take a walk stop working on the problem
for a little while
and go and do something else that
interests you
or something that's mentally stimulating
you could go to an art gallery
you could go for a run you could go to a
film festival
number five let your ideas simmer
and let it come back to you after some
time
it's gonna come back in a new form
attached to other ideas
you know if you're really focused on
trying to solve this one problem
no matter what you're doing as you're
going about your daily life
everything will inhibitively gravitate
around that and it'll feed that even if
you try your best
not to the world is just so full of
connections
and after doing that much research into
something
your idea is gonna pull other ideas
and they'll latch on to create new ideas
so many inventions throughout history
have happened
not through isolated studying but by
mingling with other ideas
and actually a lot of times by accident
you know in some way you could call it
the serendipity
but don't expect to just wake up
in that eureka moment i think these
connections build over time
so it's important for you to be
consistent in your research
and in your designing and in your
thinking and step number six
is get feedback this step is so
important you can't wait till your
product is perfect to show it to the
world
you have to show them your progress
try to explain them the idea and
get critiqued whether it's your friends
or your family and adjust your idea
based on diet
put your ego aside and then number seven
you iterate you repeat processes
three to six over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
you